Зазвичай робочий день Олесі Скрипник
був переповнений: численні відрядження, зустрічі,
керування слідством справ, а їх у колишньої прокурорки
одночасно могло бути до 20. Чи не найгучніша з них
- збиття у 2014 році пасажирського "Боїнга" рейсу MH17.
- MH17 - це була, мабуть, справа мого життя,
бо таких прецедентів у моїй кар'єрі і житті не було
і, в принципі, в Україні таких справ до того часу не було.
Над справою MH17 35-річна Олеся Скрипник
працювала майже чотири роки. Знання англійської
допомогло їй увійти в міжнародну слідчу групу
та працювати разом із правоохоронними органами
Нідерландів, Бельгії, Австралії та Малайзії.
Не применшуючи професійність міжнародних колег,
Скрипник водночас вказує, що робота саме
українських оперативників була визначальною.
Наприклад, у пошуках свідків збиття пасажирського лайнера.
- Було декілька відряджень спільних з поліцією Нідерландів
та поліцією Австралії. Я не можу казати про слідчі дії,
бо це таємниця розслідування, але кілька таких відряджень
у нас було спільних. Це було місто Маріуполь.
Те, що об'єднана слідча група JIT влітку минулого року
назвала імена перших чотирьох підозрюваних
у цій справі - частково й заслуга української юристки.
У збитті "Боїнга" підозрюються троє росіян і один українець.
Лідер бойовиків на сході України Ігор Гіркін,
позивний "Стрелков", російський генерал Сергій Дубинський - "Хмурий",
полковник Російської Федерації Олег Пулатов, позивний "Гюрза",
та українець, який воював за "ДНР" - Леонід Харченко, позивний "Кріт".
І це лише початок.
- Я вважаю, що це значний результат для нас,
як і для України. І ми планували в подальшому
керувати цією справою,
тобто були перспективи повідомлення про підозру іншим особам.
Утім, вже понад два місяці Олеся Скрипник безробітна.
З осені й донині в Україні триває реформа очищення
органів прокуратури. Кожен співробітник має
пройти переатестацію, яка складається з кількох етапів:
анонімне тестування на знання законодавства та співбесіда.
Під час переатестації усі прокурори, які займалися
справою MH17, необхідної кількості балів не набрали,
тож були звільнені. Нідерландські ЗМІ навіть
критично висвітлювали  звільнення українських прокурорів.
Натомість у головному офісі об'єднаної слідчої групи в Нідерландах
на запит DW відповіли, що змінами не стурбовані.
Неофіційно все, схоже, виглядає інакше.
Лише завдяки проханням Нідерландів вдалося
залишити в українській групі одного зі звільнених прокурорів
Олега Пересаду. Він консультуватиме нових фахівців.
DW намагалася поспілкуватися з новою командою українських прокурорів.
Адже їм, аби продовжити слідство, спершу треба
вивчити усі зібрані за п'ять років докази,
а це десятки тисяч файлів телефонних розмов, фотографій, висновків.
І це все - вже під час судового розгляду справи,
який розпочинається 9 березня в окружному суді Гааги.
Та необхідний дозвіл на зйомку нідерландська сторона не надала.
Кажуть, відтепер лише в суді зможуть вільно
говорити про розслідування. Олеся Скрипник
шкодує, що вже не є учасницею розслідування.
- Ми всі звільнені вже, жодного прокурора не залишилось,
включили в групу моїх інших колег.
Я не сумніваюся в їхній професійній діяльності,
їхньому професіоналізмові, тому що там дійсно
всі люди досвідчені. Єдине, що мене турбує, -
що за 5 років було зібрано велику кількість доказів
і для того, щоб все вивчити, потрібен, мабуть, навіть не рік.
Щоправда, й сам процес у Гаазі, ймовірно,
триватиме не менше року.  До речі, попри важливий
внесок українських слідчих, нікуди не зникли закиди
на адресу України, яка в липні 2014 року не закрила
повітряний простір над Донбасом для цивільних літаків.
Адже за три дні до "Боїнга" рейсу MH17
на висоті 6500 метрів з використанням зенітної керованої ракети
був збитий український вантажний літак АН-26.
Між іншим, на відміну від резонансної справи MH17,
збір доказів у цій справі все ще триває.
За майже шість років до суду справа не дійшла,
а особи, причетні до вчинення цього злочину, поки не встановлені.